the Biden Administration has claimed
that all sorts of political enemies pose
the greatest Terror threats to our
civilization white people grannies at
the Capitol parents who don't want their
kids being taught critical race Theory
and gay porn and kindergarten
but the science tells a different story
according to a study that was conducted
last year it's available on the NIH
website quote transgender and gender
diverse youth emerge as the group at the
highest risk of support for violent
radicalization
the study authors Define violent
radicalization as quote a complex and
multi-dimensional phenomenon defined as
a process whereby an individual or a
group increases support for violence as
a legitimate means to reach a specific
for example political social and
religious goal
of course
of course this is the case
we don't need a scientific study to tell
us that unreasonable people are the most
likely people to be unreasonable we
don't need a study to show us the
consequences of encouraging troubled
people to delve deeper into unreality
liberals have dubbed this week
the trans week of visibility
we know the horrific way the week
started in Nashville we know how it
progressed
the week progressed with a statement
from a transgender organization mourning
the death of the shooter and excusing
her Slaughter of elementary school
students as a consequence of alleged
hate
from conservatives
the week progressed with multiple
Network news outlets blaming
conservatives for provoking the shooter
because we don't think men should be
allowed in the women's bathroom because
we don't think girls should be forced to
shower with men in their locker rooms
and now the week will end with yet
another transgender group hosting a
trans day of Vengeance in Washington DC
and possibly once again in Nashville
we don't need a scientific study to tell
us that erratic and troubled people are
the people most likely to support
erratic and troubling things
and unfortunately the scientific study
probably won't do much good because the
people who most need to read it are
ruling class won't even accept the basic
science of biology I'm Michael knowlesis
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
we've got the threat of violence threat
of death all around us and then
simultaneously you have people in
Silicon Valley Computer scientists
predicting that within a matter of just
eight or so years human beings will
achieve immortality
I'm somewhat skeptical but this computer
scientist who's predicting it has a
pretty good track record which we will
get to in just a little bit
I don't want it to seem like I am I'm
just pointing to Fringe groups or weird
little social media people who are
encouraging violence on behalf of
transgenderism against conservatives
against people who think boys and girls
are different
prominent Liberals are doing this
mainstream people are doing this the
press secretary for the Democrat
Governor of Arizona Katie Hobbs
posted yesterday it posted I'm sorry
posted on the day of the Nashville
shooting by the transgender identifying
woman
this was 9 30 at night so this is many
hours after the shooting
she said us when we see transphobes
and it's a picture of a woman holding
two pistols
finger on the trip fingers on the
trigger
I was not oh just accidental wow bad
timing oh gosh this looks really bad
because there was a shooting this was
many hours after the shooting
she was posting this in response to the
shooting
she said yeah if you're a trans phobe
by which we mean if you don't believe
that men can secretly be women if you
don't think men should be able to strip
down naked in your little daughter's
changing room
then you're a transphobe and we're gonna
shoot you dead
that's what this is the press secretary
for the sitting Democrat Governor of
Arizona
she lost her job fortunately her
resignation was accepted
as far as I can tell she was allowed to
stay on social media I don't think that
tweet was taken down
my tweet was taken down my tweet was
taken down for quoting the Bible quoting
a verse of the Bible that says do not
take vengeance
quoting
one of the most Peaceable quotes in the
Bible
with beloved never avenge yourselves but
leave it to the wrath of God for it is
written vengeance is mine I will repay
says the Lord It's really two Bible
verses because it's Saint Paul quoting
Deuteronomy
and my tweet was taken down for that now
Twitter has tried to excuse this and say
well we were just trying to take down
any tweets related to the trans day of
vengeance
so it was a technical error
which if that were the case I would be
totally supportive of it
I think that's a good thing I I think
Society necessarily has standards and
norms and taboos I think that that the
powerful institutions in society have
the right and frankly obligation to
enforce proper standards and norms and
taboos and I don't think that these
Maniacs calling for violence against
normal people
ought to be able to do that on social
media so I I'm all for that in principle
this is the thesis of speechless
controlling words controlling minds but
the the what what happened with the the
Twitter incident here is that
people got caught up in this net so if
you criticized the trans day of
Vengeance then you would also be
taken off of the platform all right and
now it's come to Twitter's attention so
why aren't why aren't we being
reinstated
it's not it's not just me it's me it's
Sean Davis
I at the Federalist I think it's Luke
rosiak our own Luke rosiak I think he
got taken down there are a number of
other people I don't know how many
people because I'm not on Twitter at the
moment
but I'm not I'm not uh upset with this
in principle obviously people are always
going to be taken down from Twitter I
would much rather people be taken down
for spreading something like the trans
day of Vengeance but that's not what
happened to the conservatives so it if
Twitter reinstates our accounts okay you
know that's fine that these things
happen if not though I have to wonder is
the musk era of Twitter all that much
different from the era before this is a
it is a little strange
that the accounts
objecting to the trans day of violence
have not been reinstated whereas the the
some accounts calling for
transgender activists to murder
quote unquote transphobes those accounts
are still online that doesn't that
doesn't make a lot of sense to me
now speaking of Elon Musk Elon Musk has
just issued a very powerful statement
not on Twitter on the future of
computing and the future of humanity
which we'll get to in one second when
things go crazy you're going to want to
have reliable tangible assets you're
going to want to check out Birch gold
right now text Knowles to 98 98 98 the
FED has a tendency to print money during
times of economic distress like they did
during the covid-19 pandemic this has
resulted in the loss of value of a
dollar and an increase in the value of
precious metals like gold gold will
always have value because it's a
tangible and finite resource
uncontrolled by any single government or
financial institution gold cannot simply
be printed on a whim like paper currency
as the value of our dollar continues to
decline it becomes increasingly
important to hedge against inflation by
diversifying at least some of your
assets
into precious metals the only company I
trust to help you diversify into
precious metals is Birch gold
Birch gold also makes it easy to convert
your IRA or 401K into an IRA backed by
physical gold and silver with an A plus
rating with the Better Business Bureau
thousands of happy customers and
countless five-star reviews Birch gold
is the company I trust to protect my
future and so should you text nulls
kwles to 98 9898 to claim your free info
kit on gold today and talk to a precious
metals expert that's Knowles kwles to 98
98 98 Elon Musk
has just signed a statement with Wozniak
from Apple
with a lot of top computer scientists
and AI Developers
urging a six-month moratorium on the
development of AI
I signed up yesterday for one of the
fancy AI programs where you have to pay
like 10 bucks a month to be able to try
it out and I did it because I heard that
these fancier AI programs were much much
much more impressive than the freebies
that everybody gets to try out and so I
thought all right I want to see how good
this stuff really is
it's unbelievable the artwork that it
can produce the
compositions that these programs can
produce it is unbelievable a lot of
people thought that AI might be useful
for calculations for
some aspects of business but the one
thing they could never do is create art
or poetry that's something that only
humans can do and what do we find out
the thing that AI is best at perhaps is
Art and poetry so we just don't really
know what this thing is and how
how far it's going to go and how quickly
it's going to go that far so what Elon
and the other people have suggested is
quote such decisions
about the development of AI must not be
delegated to unelected Tech leaders
powerful AI systems should be developed
only once we're confident that their
effects will be positive and their risks
will be manageable this confidence must
be well Justified this is of course true
and you might hear some people insist I
either on the left or on the right
insists that no we can't have the
government limit creativity that's
probably what you hear from the left or
you might hear her from the right you
can't have the government stop the
progress of the free market or whatever
but
AI is potentially very very dangerous
AI will almost certainly transform our
society in ways that we haven't seen
certainly since the development of the
internet maybe since the development of
industrialization maybe since the
development of who knows
and so the point that Elon is making and
Wozniak and the rest of the compsi guys
is is not even a point about AI
it's a point about politics
whatever happens with AI
a development at this scale
is a political matter
in recent decades our conception of
politics has become really really
shallow and narrow
on the left the the leftists have said
Paul keep your politics out of my
bedroom keep your politics out of my
drug bin keep your politics out of
whatever I want to do socially and on
the right the conservatives have said
keep your politics out of my business
keep your politics out of my bank
account keep your politics out of my
personal life but politics is just what
we do together politics just means
public
and and the
the conception of politics at the
founding of our country was a much more
robust conception the whole idea of
self-government is that we're going to
be really involved in politics and we're
going to come to conclusions about the
world and how we want to live and then
we're going to impose them on the
society through our through our vote and
through our elected representatives
could you imagine if the nuclear bomb
were being developed
just after it was developed and then
the nuclear bomb were strictly A Private
Matter
so keep your politics out of my business
man we're building a bomb no of course
not it's a highly political matter and
people have the right to put some
limitations on it the fact that
we haven't seen nuclear weapons used in
war since World War II is very
impressive and it attests to the ability
of political action to keep a handle on
things in society I think I think Elon
is totally right I'm still miffed that
I'm not on Twitter right now so Elon
please take put me back on Twitter and
don't boot me off of The Social Network
for quoting the Bible but he's
absolutely right about about AI this is
a political decision and speaking of the
political fight we have potentially a
new candidate in the 2024 presidential
race
I'm not even going to let you guess this
is not a candidate that anybody would
have been guessing
from New Hampshire on the campaign Trail
we cut two
Chris Christie
soon
because that's the only thing
that's going to defeat Donald Trump
and that means you gotta have the skill
to do it
and that means you have to be Fearless
because he will come back
and right action
and so you need to think about
who's got the skill to do that and who's
got the guts to do it because it's not
going to end nicely
no matter what his ends will not be a
calm and quiet conclusion if I run again
I can't imagine that I wouldn't continue
doing the same way because I think it's
the best way to communicate but this
time
if I run
I would just hope that you come to a
better conclusion into the last time
so he has a little joke there uh it
didn't work out last time that I ran but
at this time maybe I could run look he's
up in New Hampshire
he's talking about
how how talented he is at politics and
destroying people on the debate stage he
makes a good point about Trump he says
Trump's Trump's not going quietly
some of the people now especially the
people who were backing who were
formally backing Ron DeSantis or even
people formally backing the other
candidates who are in the race who are
much lower in the polls than Ron
DeSantis they'll say why can't Trump
just step down and go away and and Usher
in a new era of Republicans
yeah I don't know how come the sun's got
to shine how come Birds gotta fly it
Trump is never gonna do that okay how
come reality isn't the is the way that
it is it's just it is man and and if you
can deny it all you want but that's not
going to change anything
so Christy saying no he's not going to
go quietly into that night and so
someone's got to have the skill and the
talent to destroy him on the base age
and the way that I destroyed Marco Rubio
you remember Chris Christie absolutely
short-circuited Marco Rubio it was a
brilliant debate performance and it
destroyed Rubio's candidacy
but Christy didn't do that to Trump
they were running against each other he
just couldn't do it
nobody did it to Trump
I'm not convinced anybody can do it to
Trump maybe Ron DeSantis can we'll see
that in the primary campaign
I'm not really convinced anybody can do
it though
so this
ought to be a warning
Chris Christie means this as a warning
to the other candidates
to to mean you guys better be ready for
what you're in for because Trump's going
to come at you like a freight train to
me that's not the warning I think this
is a clear warning to Ron DeSantis but
the real warning to Ron DeSantis here is
know your moment the real warning that
Chris Christie gives to Ron DeSantis is
don't miss your moment Chris Christie
would have been a formidable
presidential candidate in 2012. he had
some of the biggest names in politics
calling him saying run run run he I
think could he was riding high as the
governor of New Jersey he had a little
bit of crossover appeal because he was
from a blue state but he had a lot of
conservative support he certainly had
more support among conservatives than
Mitt Romney did
but he chose not to run he said I'm not
ready
then by the time he is ready no one
wants him to be president anymore
politics changes so quickly especially
presidential politics this is Ron
desantis's moment this is this moment
right now is for Ron DeSantis what 2012
was for Chris Christie
if DeSantis doesn't run now I'm not
convinced he will ever have another
moment I'm not saying that Ron DeSantis
will win if he runs now he might get
completely destroyed by Donald Trump
but this is his moment and you can see
Christy even all these years later after
2012 which was his moment we're now over
a decade later and he just wants that
presidency so bad but it will continue
to elude him now all that said Trump is
dominating the field there's a new poll
out from Quinnipiac Trump is 14 points
ahead of of Ron DeSantis who's the
number two Challenger and no one else
comes even close
so that's in a field with multiple
candidates Nikki Haley Mike Pence
they're polling for Ted Cruz even though
Senator Cruz doesn't appear that he's
going to run Vivek ramaswamis on the
board with a point which is quite
impressive for a candidate who came out
of nowhere and has very low name
recognition the very beginning of his
campaign so even with all those
candidates Trump's got a 14-point lead
and then they measured head-to-head
against Ron DeSantis in a head-to-head
matchup Trump is still leading by 10
points 52-42
and Trump has a higher favorable rating
over Republicans
then DeSantis does because the whole
argument is that Trump is deeply
unlikable and that's why we have to move
on from him well he's got a higher
favorable rating that's close to Santa's
is very likable too but it's 79 to 72.
so the race remains as I've said from
the beginning the race is Trump's to
lose he is still the favorite he's where
the money ought to be can Ron DeSantis
turn that around he might well be able
to do it will he be the nominee he might
well be the nominee right now
no matter what you're hearing from the
chattering class and all the political
operatives right now the numbers are
quite clear this is still Trump's race
so what happens whoever gets it Trump
DeSantis Vivek I don't know whoever gets
it the challenge
is to restore not just the GOP not just
conservatism
Capital C trademark over the M but to
restore the country the country is in
deep trouble we've been talking all week
about how the country has just gone
crazy
why is that there's a new poll out from
the Wall Street Journal norc it shows
that support for traditional American
values has declined it's declined
precipitously almost across the board
this poll measured five areas
patriotism Community involvement
religion having children and money only
one of those has increased guess which
one I think you know
the people still like making money
people still support making money but
all the other ones have declined
precipitously
so now we are just worshiping Mammon
here what's it say in the Bible seek ye
first money and then all the other stuff
will follow no I don't think I don't
think that's quite what it says
all of the things that make our country
great
people no longer value
patriotism religion having kids
Community involvement
just money we value how'd that happen it
hasn't happened in a vacuum
sometimes you will hear feckless
well-intentioned conservatives say well
we've just gotta you know encourage
people we got to restore those values
the values haven't collapsed in a vacuum
they've been crowded out they've been
replaced by other values
other values that conservatives have
failed to suppress have failed to refute
in the name of the free Marketplace of
ideas and neutrality and the blessings
of liberty to support things like drag
queen Story Hour we have surrendered our
deeply held political beliefs
and we've we've surrendered that ground
to these values why is patriotism on the
decline because the libs have enshrined
in our education system in our culture
in our law in some places
anti-americanism multiculturalism the
idea that America is evil that's what
kids are taught now that's what kids are
taught in government schools that's the
position of the state is that America is
bad and that nationalism is bad and that
we all should just be citizens of the
world coming by yeah that's why it's
declined why is religion declined
because the state has decided to ban the
Bible from schools and ban prayer from
schools and ban religion in many ways
from public life
that's why it wasn't an organic
development it was imposed by political
activists wielding political power why
is having kids on the way down because
the government decided to encourage
contraception the government decided to
enshrine Baby Slaughter abortion as a
matter of law fortunately now we've had
a reprieve from that we've overruled Roe
v Wade so there's a chance to push back
for a culture of Life why is community
involvement down because the state has
grown uh immense land taken over a lot
of areas that were previously controlled
by Charities and Civic associations
because religion has declined because of
of economic policies that have destroyed
communities that have destroyed towns
that have intentionally shipped jobs
overseas shipped manufacturing overseas
hollowed at the American middle class
that's why it hasn't happened in a
vacuum this has been a deliberate agenda
I'm not saying it's a shadowy cabal
that's intent on destroying our nation I
suppose it might be but it might be a
not so shadowy cabal that pursued a
political agenda that has harmed our
country and that is put forward terrible
beliefs because they sincerely believe
them but they're sincerely wrong and we
need to have the courage and the clarity
to say you are sincerely wrong you're
not going to teach that crap in schools
you're not going to kick the Bible out
of schools and replace it with gay porn
and genderqueer and all this other
degeneracy we're not going to allow you
to ship our jobs overseas and to destroy
our communities and we're not going to
we're not going to tolerate a national
policy of of
stopping people from having kids and
destroying marriage we're not we're just
going to say no you're imposing your
terrible values on us we're going to say
no to that and we're going to reimpose
true belief we're going to reimpose
ideas and institutions that are
conducive to human flourishing because
politics is not merely Downstream of
culture the law is also a teacher if you
want to have a better culture and you
want to have a better country we need to
get serious about political action this
is supposed to be a self-government
all politics of course boils down to
religion ultimately all human conflict
is theological
so I would strongly recommend you get
your prayer life in order and you check
out hallow right now go to hallow.com
Knowles in a society Rife with
anti-religious ideologies like the ones
we hear from the libs on a daily basis
it can be incredibly challenging to
ground oneself in what we know to be
true and good during the season of Lent
it's more important than ever to embrace
our faith and start building a habit of
prayer and meditation join me and
thousands of others on hallow the number
one Christian Prayer app in the United
States hallow is helping all of us to
maintain a daily prayer routine it can
help you right now download the app for
free at hallow.com
you can set prayer reminders and track
your progress along the way you're not
sure where to start maybe check out my
favorite podcast father Mike schmitz's
Bible in a year available on the Hallow
app for brief daily readings and
Reflections or pray alongside Mark
Wahlberg and Jonathan Rooney who
portrays Jesus in The Chosen with hallow
you can customize a personal prayer plan
that works for you listen wherever you
are with downloadable offline sessions
the download hello.com Knowles and get
an exclusive three months free which
will carry you through Easter and lent
that is three months free at hallow.com
Knowles
what values are we supporting
all the traditional American values have
collapsed other than making money so
what values are we supporting
we conservatives according to NBC
Republicans and conservatives
we are turning to anti-trans rhetoric
the conversation is pivoting too when it
comes to some more conservative
lawmakers from changing gun laws to
something like mental health for example
other Republicans to anti-trans rhetoric
or to calling this a hate crime against
Christians it seems like that's where
the conversation is at least in the
House of Representatives
yeah there's been a long list that's
evolved over the years where uh you know
a lot of pro-gun lawmakers have been
appointing the the blame it's gone from
video games there's a lot of talk about
mental health alienation uh now there's
some focus on the fact that the shooter
was apparently transgender but the
bottom line is Republicans don't want to
you know tighten gun laws and as a
result a number of these other
explanations are coming up
I think they're getting the order
backwards saying listen these
Republicans really just they don't want
to ban guns and so they're coming up ex
post facto with all these ridiculous
explanations of why America's lost its
mind uh but but it's all just because
they don't want to ban guns which are
obviously the real problem as I pointed
out on this show the only thing we know
cannot lie at the cause of an increase
in these mass shooting events these
school shooting events he's particularly
gruesome crimes the only thing that
cannot explain that
is guns
because guns have not really changed
over the last century guns have existed
for a thousand years and they have
improved in lethality over time but they
haven't really changed in the last
hundred years the machine gun was
invented in 1884 the portable machine
gun the Tommy Gun was invented in 1918 a
lot more deadly than whatever rifles you
can go by at Walmart right now
furthermore the AK-47 was invented in
1947 that's where the name came from the
AR-10 and the AR-15 were invented in the
1950s
it was a long time ago these guns have
all been around for a very long time
that's not what's changed
what has changed is our approach to
mental health and spiritual reality and
political institutions
an approach which has
caused all of those to collapse
hasn't caused the one thing it hasn't
caused to collapse is spiritual reality
it's just caused our relationship to
spiritual reality to become deeply
deeply perverted
so now the GOP is turning to anti-trans
rhetoric what is anti-trans rhetoric I
don't even know what that means
I know what pro-reality rhetoric is I
engage in pro-reality rhetoric
I I that's my favorite kind of rhetoric
rhetoric can be used to any persuasive
end rhetoric doesn't necessarily need to
concern itself with true things
this is Plato's criticism and the and
Plato's socrates's criticism of the
rhetoricians and the sophists
is that they don't care about the truth
they don't care about philosophy I I
want to make sure that
whatever rhetoric I'm engaging in is
concerned primarily with the truth and
the truth is that a man can't really be
a woman and a woman can't really be a
man and I know that seems to irritate
some people and I know that seems that
that basic statement of reality seems to
provoke some people to violence
but it's the truth and I'm not going to
lie and you people are not going to make
me lie
you on NBC you in the White House
you activists threatening us with a day
of Vengeance none of you are going to
make me lie
anti-trans rhetoric what does that mean
it means
you think that men and women are
different that they're real natural
categories
and little girls should not be forced to
get changed in a locker room with deeply
confused naked men
that's what it means if that's
anti-trans rhetoric I guess I'm engaged
in it you know why I'm engaged in it
because it's true
our entire culture our entire legal
system our entire government should be
engaged whenever this issue comes up in
anti-trans rhetoric
not rhetoric
aimed against people who are confused
rather rhetoric aimed at the Absurd
ideology that is confusing those people
because that ideology is harming a lot
of people it's harming the people who
have fallen prey to its deception and
it's harming the people
that those deceived people are now
harming and advocating that others harm
as well
we we should all always engage in Pro
reality rhetoric from the highest level
there's no neutrality here there's no
middle ground
there's no middle ground between clear
truth and clear falsehood pick a side
the state is not neutral you know how I
know the state's not neutral
you remember back
when Roe v Wade was overruled
when there was a late document from a
court leaker whose identity apparently
we're never going to know there were
only about a dozen people that it could
possibly be but for some reason we still
don't know who leaked that document out
of the Supreme Court
and it was leaked to put political
pressure on the judges and to threaten
the judges with violence to change their
vote before
Robbie Wade was overruled and the and
the license National license to abortion
was declared
silly
so there were protests outside of the
judge's homes Kavanaugh Alito Barrett I
think Roberts too
there was an attempted assassination of
Justice Kavanaugh
and the question at the time was why are
these protesters allowed to protest it's
a federal crime to protest
at a judge's home certainly really even
at a courthouse with the intention of
changing the verdict in a case that's a
federal crime it's defined in the U.S
code
why were these people not arrested why
were they not dispersed
well now we know according to documents
obtained by Alabama Republican senator
Katie Britt
Joe Biden's attorney general Merrick
Garland ordered the U.S Marshals not to
arrest the protesters he said it
shouldn't be a top priority this being
reported by Washington Times
Merrick Garland told Senators earlier
this month as prosecutors could not
bring cases against these criminals who
were intimidating judges
and in one case then ultimately
attempted to kill a judge
unless those Marshals made arrests and
the marshals on the scene didn't think
there was reason to do that but that was
a BS explanation
the reason they didn't think there was
reason to do that
is because Merrick arlem told them not
to
so Garland
told the marshals to stand down
encouraged the leftists to break the law
to try to influence the decision and
then lied to the Senate
they were actively discouraged from
arresting the protesters
according to these documents
that was the political purpose that the
Biden Administration wanted to affect
law be damned
no neutrality here folks if you if you
lament that American values have
declined
just look at the values that have
replaced them you're going to believe
something or another everybody's got to
serve somebody are we going to have the
clarity and the courage to impose our
vision I think our vision is true I
think our vision is good for everybody
you know the libs are going to impose
their Vision on us their vision is evil
their vision is harmful to everybody
which is it going to be
are we going to have the courage
to govern ourselves
you know post-modernism's belief that
truth and Beauty are subjective as
flawed and extends to fundamental beings
the fundamental beings such as God Keith
Getty songwriter responsible for for a
modern day hymn discusses this idea in
Jordan Peterson's logos and literacy
John 1 begins with in the beginning was
the word the word was with God
the Word was God
God is before all time
if he is the creator of the world he
created beauty
and Truth are linked together the
postmodernists will tell us that beauty
doesn't exist it only exists in in
whatever you can create for yourself and
life
but we believe that all the evidence
around us points to a world to music to
human love that all point to beauty that
point to a Creator God
here is where I would normally tell you
that logos and literacy is only for
daily wear Plus members but we are
making it available for free for
everyone at dailywireplus.com only for a
limited time so watch logos and literacy
today at
dailywireplus.com my favorite comment
yesterday is from Maria Marconi
who says the subtlety and delicacy with
which the editing team removes language
that YouTube censors is stunning what
Artistry what technical Precision thank
you very much all credit there goes to
producer Danny because
there are certain things and big Tech
has clamped down on this in recent weeks
there's certain things where if you say
it
your video will be removed you get a
strike they'll nuke your channel and
that's it you're out
you can't get a message out to the
zillions and zillions of people on these
platforms so I refuse to be censored
but I also refuse to commit seppuku on
these platforms so that the libs can say
I censored myself
so how do we get around it well the way
we get around it is
really talented editors making clear
exactly what the story is and what the
truth is but if you want to hear all of
the exact words you got to go to daily
wire Plus
that's that's how we can be wise as
serpents and innocent as doves over
dailywire.com use promo code Knowles you
will get two months free
then we can all keep chatting together
perhaps in perpetuity
and when I say in perpetuity I mean
perpetuity I mean forever because
according to Ray Kurzweil
we are on the brink of immortality
there's an old clip resurfix saying from
a documentary about reiker as well
Ray Kurzweil is a computer scientist and
he's
much respected in Silicon Valley and has
been for decades now and Ray Kurzweil
has predicted
that within about eight or so years
mankind will achieve
in this world
eternal life
Kurzweil says revolutions and genetics
nanotechnology and Robotics will Usher
in the beginning of the singularity
kurzwill feels with sufficient genetic
technology it should be possible to
maintain the body indefinitely reversing
aging while curing cancer heart disease
and other illnesses Kurzweil envisions
Nanobots which allow people to eat
whatever they want while remaining thin
and fit provide copious energy fight off
infections or cancer replace organs and
augment their brains eventually people's
bodies will contain so much augmentation
they'll be able to alter their physical
manifestation at will Kurzweil writes
that by 2010 a supercomputer will have
the computational capacity to emulate
human intelligence and by around 2020
this same capacity will be available for
one thousand dollars after that
Milestone he expects human brain
scanning to contribute to an effective
model of human intelligence by the
mid-2020 these two elements will
culminate in computers that can pass the
touring test by 2029 by the early 2030
the amount of non-biological computation
will exceed the capacity of all living
biological human intelligence
so this is not a new documentary this is
obviously not a new prediction raker as
well has made all sorts of predictions
over the years you might say this is
totally far-fetched and then you just
start hearing some of his predictions
say well he did say did kind of predict
when AI would start to really develop in
any kind of predicted oh almost
perfectly when AI would really start to
take off and he's made a lot of other
predictions too
according to
Ray Kurzweil and his supporters
out of the 147
discrete predictions he has made about
technology and Humanity in the future 86
percent of them
have come true
so are we going to live forever here on
Earth
I don't believe it I I don't quite
believe it 86 percent right means that
you were wrong 14 of the time I'm no
mathematician but that's I think how the
numbers work out and
here's why I think that
here are some of the other predictions
Ray Kurzweil has made he accurately
predicted that consumers will be able to
design their own clothes with precise
measurements and style requirements from
home computers by 1999.
and that that happened
the world's best chess player would lose
to a computer by 2000 that happened
deep blue totally destroyed Kasparov
with facts and logic
that people would primarily use portable
computers in a wide range of sizes and
shapes by 2009 2009 Maps almost exactly
with the development of the iPhone here
we go I got this one over here we have
all sorts of super computers yep little
miniature miniature computers rather and
the majority of the world would have
high bandwidth wireless internet access
at all times by 2010 seems to have
basically come true
all of those predictions are rather
Limited in scope though
those are the kinds of predictions that
futurists and technology-minded people
have accurately made
for centuries now
the immortality prediction is something
that power mad Fallen humans have have
predicted and sought after since the
dawn of time
since
since the earliest mythical conceptions
of humanity we have sought after that
and I don't I don't see it happening
just as Adam and Eve in the Garden of
Eden might have reached for that tree of
the knowledge well they did reach for
the the fruit of the tree of the
knowledge of Good and Evil but they
might have reached for the tree of life
and they were booted out of the garden
just as
the ancient Babylonians were building up
that Tower of Babel they were just about
to reach heaven and then they were all
scattered I just don't think we get
there I think that
human beings
even if we're even if we're blundering
into that sort of thing we we will be
protected for our own good by our own
incompetence and I just
I just don't buy it I think these are
people who could have eternal life if
they wanted it they just got to say the
word they're not going to do it through
their own efforts and their own
computers
now
where does America stand America
is uh
at a Crossroads because both sides seem
to not like the country that much
anymore the left doesn't like America
because of what America has been
America's so evil it's got the original
sin and so that's the slavery and so
it's always bigoted and evil and the
right is increasingly disenchanted with
America because America is standing for
what America is standing against the
rule of law standing against
self-government America standing against
Christianity America standing against
even the distinction between men and
women and America's values that we're
exporting around the world are what it's
wokeness and the rainbow flag
you just have the Pentagon confirm that
lgbtism is a key American value that we
are protecting overseas
that's what we're that's what we're
exporting no longer truth justice in the
American way we're just trying to raise
a pride flag in Kandahar okay count me
out of intervention then I guess Sunny
Hosten made this point on The View Sunny
host and one of the cackling hens who
who said America we're no better than
any other country around the world
when I listened to Christopher Ray the
Pres the the head of the FBI he said
white supremacy is the biggest domestic
threat to this country and so as a woman
of color with a six foot two black kid
in college and a five foot seven five
foot eight black kid in high school I
don't see that part of American
exceptionalism I'm sorry I think this
country has a lot of problems that could
be solved yes maybe they're putting
Muslims in jail in Afghanistan I think
you mentioned and China they're putting
a lot of black more black people in jail
there it is so so yeah sure China is
engaged in a process of mass
sterilization they've long been engaged
in a process of Mass Slaughter through
abortion and yeah they're they're
engaged in ethnic cleansing and they're
sending a particular religious and
ethnic group to a prison camp
but
America arrests Black Street criminals
so it's like kind of it's kind of the
same thing right I don't think it's the
same thing
you'll see a lot of knee-jerk right-wing
reactions to this clip from The View
they'll say you're anti-American how
dare you make a comparison between
America and any other country on earth I
don't think that's
necessarily Beyond The Pale I'm not
opposed in principle to making these
kinds of comparisons I made one of these
comparisons yesterday
I said that the United States we allege
that we're going to ban Tick-Tock that's
why the the unit party in Washington DC
is in favor of this bill to restrict act
to ban Tick Tock except the bill doesn't
ban Tick Tock what it does is it gives
the government and unaccountable
bureaucrats more control over what
people get to say on the internet
that's my problem with it
we point out that China has a social
credit score well America in many ways
is a social credit score if you say
things that are heterodox or if you say
things that contradict the the
prevailing line of the regime or if you
say things that are genuinely nasty
you can be completely ostracized from
society put on a no-fly list debanked
kicked off of every social platform
you're just done
is that so different from a social
credit score China has mass surveillance
oh you want to talk to Americans about
Mass surveillance
uh yeah I think
I think uh we we know a thing or two
about surveillance of our own citizens
in this country well in China they
arrest political dissidents oh uh yeah
tell me how are the grannies doing in
solitary confinement because they
decided to take a picture in the capital
rotunda on January 6th the worst day
ever in the history of the world
yeah no I look these comparisons are
fine
to make it's a way of improving our own
country but the comparison that Sunny
Hosten is making here is in apt
what Sunny Hosten is doing is simply
encouraging criminality
saying yeah the Chinese are persecuting
the uyghurs the way the American
government persecutes black men the
difference is the uyghurs aren't
committing crimes
they're not having the law which applies
to everybody just enforced against them
sometimes frankly not even all of the
time which is what we're talking about
here when you say well black men are
being arrested at disproportionately
high rates
not really they're they're just
committing crimes at disproportionately
high rates when did it we're not so
it'd be great let's try to reform
something that's fine by me but the libs
don't want to reform anything in fact
the lips want to encourage criminality
and go easier on the criminals which
means they won't be rehabilitated they
won't be reformed these problems are
going to persist they're going to plague
in particular
these communities
but if you go soft on it you're just
going soft on crime which is of course
what the libs want to do
the libs encourage this criminality
because it allows them to clamp down and
claim more power and it allows them to
use
these groups of people
as a cudgel to intimidate
ordinary innocent
civilians I'm not just talking about
Street criminals in the inner cities I'm
talking about people at universities
there's a Wayne State University
professor
Stephen shaviro
who has just come out and encouraged
leftists to murder
me to murder me to murder Matt Walsh to
murderer Ben tomorrow all of us here at
the daily wire and to murder Tennessee
legislators and to to but specifically
to murder conservatives who come to
college campuses and speak out in
defense of reality against the absurdity
of transgender ideology here's what he
said he said here's what I think about
free speech on campus although I do not
Advocate violating federal and state
criminal codes I think it is far more
admirable to kill a racist homophobic or
here's the key transphobic
speaker than it is to shout them down
what does transphobic mean it means
pro-reality
transphobic the irrational fear of
of affirming Disturbed people in their
misperception of reality
of encouraging people who according to
at least one major study
are
the most likely to support violent
radicalization to encourage them to kill
us that's what the professor has done
the professor has been suspended he
obviously should have been fired on the
spot
and perhaps should be prosecuted I'm not
sure that this statement Rises quite to
the level of a direct threat but we are
all giving speeches now we'll see I've
got a lot of speeches lined up I have no
intention of shutting them down there I
think that we'll we'll see how how much
Vengeance the the libs are trying to
reek but as of now all of these speeches
are on
and we're going to continue
we're going to continue to speak the
truth and I don't care if some Wayne
State University Professor is
threatening to or encouraging his
students to kill us all
we will not be made in lies this is we
will not be made to live in Wise this is
this is the
greatest political revolution in the
history of the world it's the political
revolution of Christianity
until the Incarnation and the
crucifixion and the resurrection
until that time political rulers had a
trump card which is if you don't do what
we say even if what we say is harmful
even if we if what we say is false if
you don't live according to the lies
that we insist you live under we will
kill you
and that was that and that's the end of
life and then you're over and what the
pivot of History the Incarnation
inaugurates is a period in which
political rulers lost that trump card
because no matter how tyrannical and
Powerful a political ruler is they can't
they can't take away your soul and they
can't take away your eternal life
they can they can make you scream but
they can't make you talk
they can't make you repeat their lines
they can make you scream they can harm
your body but they can't take away
your life ultimately they can't take
away your life we've got a lot more
coming up in the member block
got a lot on a i producer Jacob has
taken over the show today we'll see how
he does head on over to the Knowles
stradamus member room segmentum
dailywire.com Knowles promo code Knowles
to check out for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
foreign